you may now kiss let that sweet moment
right there remind you that sure 90 day
fiance might be full of wild fights
breakups
hey fan breakdowns oh my gosh
but there are also some seriously
touching funny candy canes are good for
you it makes your breath smell good and
heartwarming moments
we fans can be proud of we love you we
love you so much
even if they didn't last long all it
took was two or three months to pass and
everything was forgotten
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
let's take a look at the top 5 90-day
fiance moments in 2021 they gave us all
the feel marlene hold it still
it sounds like fun
coming in at number five is angela's
grandkids giving their honest feedback
on her vegetable smoothies i've been
trying really hard to eat healthy
[Music]
[Applause]
any time angela is around her grandkids
i love it because they truly bring out
the best in her i'm just i'm grateful
i'm just i'm just so grateful during
this episode angela just had her weight
loss surgery and she'd already lost over
40 pounds but the doctor told her that
in order to keep it going she needs to
eat healthy and so do the people around
her are you ready let's hope this works
girls
that's disgusting nemo makes the best
dumplings but terrible smoothies
i did not feel good after that
the funny thing is that she didn't feel
good after that but once angela added
grape jelly to the smoothie at her
request that better be good it finally
got the thumbs up
kids all right ready
[Music]
pretty good
i believe you found something
angela's other grandchildren came in and
tried it and it made this little cutie
in the red gets moving that's when you
know something is good you start dancing
[Music]
keeping things going on the kid train
number four goes to the heartwarming
moment when hazel included tariq's
daughter ari in her vows tariq has
always been open about how much he loves
being a father to his daughter and he
expressed real concerns about how she
would react to hazel moving in with them
which had hazel nervous tariq and ori
are very close
and i am worried if
i'm not fit
in in their relationship but after ari
and hazel finally met in person we
watched their bond grow
it's also important to note that hazel
had to leave her son back in the
philippines
something she would get emotional about
often i miss my son very much
but that guilt didn't stop her from
embracing ari as her own
sorry
i promise i've been real to you
and
i've heard why and a stepmom for art
i love you
both forever and ever
it was horrible babes i know
i can't imagine in the third spot is
ellie leaving her life in the u.s and
traveling to providencia columbia to be
with her boyfriend victor after a
category 5 hurricane completely
devastated the island yeah i mean that
experience was one of the craziest
experiences of my life before the
hurricane ellie was already making a lot
of sacrifices for this relationship she
gave up her pizza restaurant sold all
her things and left her friends all to
move to this small island to be with
victor
but just days before she was set to
leave the hurricane hit the island and
she lost all connection to him i am
terrified about
what's happened there
i mean he could be dead
without hearing directly from victor
ellie still got on that plane and went
to find her man
and she did she found him thankfully
safe and well
oh oh my god
hello
hello
the day after ellie landed in san andres
a location close to the island of
providencia victor called saying he was
okay
oh no you're not yes
ellie didn't waste any time getting to
that airport and it led to this
beautiful reunion oh my god
[Music]
i never thought i would see you again
[Music]
it was horrible babes i know i can't
imagine that's love you can tell that it
was the moment victor truly needed after
experiencing such a traumatic event i
really
thought
she didn't gonna calm down after the
hurricane
when i saw her
i had some hopes to be happy again to
get a kiss from someone again
after
i almost
died me
kiss me like you'll never see me again
i didn't think i would get this
emotional but wow
but wow the number two spot on the
countdown goes to jenny breaking down in
tears after seeing herself as a bride on
her and submits wedding day
today's my wedding day and i'm getting
married
considering everything jenny has gone
through before this moment years of
submits parents
getting cold feet and blocking their
marriage paperwork behind her back this
is stupid i'm not doing this anymore
considering all that
this moment was about so much more than
jenny looking beautiful although that
dress and jewelry combo was everything
that dress what i got married in was the
first thing that i tried on beyond all
of that this moment symbolized that
nothing is more powerful than
[Music]
because lord knows we know jenny loves
cement
[Music]
after all she went through
that's something he never
passed it out thank you so much you guys
[Music]
i think it's just beautiful
wow
just beautiful just amazing
i didn't think i would get this
emotional but wow
but wow
i'm just overwhelmed i really am
very overwhelmed right now
can't even believe this is happening
finally
smith who looked like a king
topped off this touching moment by
telling his queen what i think any woman
would love to hear on their wedding day
jenny
[Music]
yes i'm coming
oh my god
look at you oh my god
wow
are looking
gorgeous like most beautiful person i
ever seen
wow
my god
and my god you two
so amazing baby
all right the most heartwarming 90-day
fiance moment of 2021 goes to armando's
dad celebrating his love for kenneth at
their wedding despite years of not
accepting armando's sexuality
since armando joined the show we watched
him struggle with his family not fully
accepting his relationship with kenny
i thought it would go better than this
his dad wouldn't even come out the house
when kenny and armando would visit
yesterday
and as time went on his mom and his
sister came around but his dad
not so much i don't know i'm afraid as
armando and kenny were preparing for
their wedding
one thing that would overshadow
armando's happiness was wondering if his
dad would show up
in
[Music]
he said he didn't know if he would come
but when the day came
he showed up and shed all the tears
good tears
los de claro officialmente casa
esproso you may now kiss
[Applause]
i'll now present you
mr and mr
kenneth and armando neither maya romeo
after they said i do they went to take
family pictures and if this next moment
doesn't show you that with time people's
hearts can really change
i don't know it will
[Applause]
is
[Music]
that was such a beautiful moment
and as 90 day fiance's first male gay
couple
[Applause]
kenny and armando's goal was for their
journey to inspire and that
it did i hope it helps a lot of young
people out there that might be
struggling and
to be able to accept themselves love
themselves and know that it it's better
at the end of the time
all right 90 day fans fam that does it
for 90 day fiance's most heartwarming
moments of 2021. happy holidays and
happy new year
[Music]
i wish you love health joy and peace in
2022
see you next time
[Music]
you